early twenties i was diagnosed with a
brain tumor that was the first knock
down
holly tucker ex-ceo and founder of not
on the high street holly's story
is mind-blowing we go and pitch the idea
of not on the high street to
the land of vcs who would tell us that
it was lovely that us women
wanted to create a crafts website but
really there was nothing in it
and i just said well we're actually
going to change the face of retailing
funny enough
it's not craft website we tried to build
a marketplace with
no tech experience but we knew what we
wanted and so we found someone
who built the technology that ebay were
building in america
and we just relaunched and we nailed it
how could i smile or laugh
i found myself becoming a different
version of me
one of the lines at hollandco is
bringing colour to grey and i think i
was turning grey
holly tucker ex-ceo and founder of
not on the high street one of the uk's
most loved brands
but a real pioneer in its space at its
time holly's story
is mind-blowing how she rose from
someone that had no experience
didn't have huge amounts of capital at a
time when women in business
especially women in tech had it harder
than anybody else
she built an online tech company
that went on to be worth hundreds and
hundreds of millions
but her story isn't straightforward it's
riddled with pain
divorce heartbreak turmoil
and having to reinvent and refine
herself time
and time again the fundamental life
lessons
that she shares today and that she
unpacks for us
are life lessons based on problems that
we're all going to experience in our
lives it's a real joy to bring you this
conversation
and i want to thank holly for her
openness her intellect and her
incredibly inspiring personality
without further ado i'm stephen barlow
and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
i always start in the same place in this
podcast because i think it provides the
greatest amount of context on a person
so i i'm i'm somewhat sort of
bored of asking these questions but
they're so incredibly foundational to
who you went on to become
because everything from you know the
start of your journey till now proves
that you are
clearly an outlier in every way so tell
me
below the age of 18 what were the
factors that went into making
that person that went on to become this
person
well um i was nicknamed holly hurricane
and that was because i couldn't
wait to get to the next stage so
when i um you know turned i think it was
12
i persuaded my dad that i needed to get
a job in a pub
cleaning it so he would wait outside in
the car park at five o'clock in the
morning i don't think i'd do this for my
son by the way anymore but
he would wait outside the um the pub and
would um pick me up after my shift
i went on and then i just continually
worked when my friends weren't working
i um decided that you know i needed the
first mobile phone you know one of those
bricks
i think it was one to one i think that
it only worked in the m25 and
um and so i was just continually pushing
it
to be grown up or to be out of childhood
i think
and so why um
because i was in i think and still am
today
incredibly excited by life i i really
wanted to juice life and i was
ready to work and i think work has
always been
um an incredibly important thing i
remember at
15 um becoming an intern
for publicist advertising agency um on
bake street
so as my friends would spend the summer
out in the
you know getting up to mischief no doubt
i would be traveling up to bake street
to spend my summer working and i did
that when i was 15
16 and 17 and it actually and
ended up being on the day of my a-level
results my
mum waited around the corner and i went
for a job interview
on the same day i was getting these
a-level results in the morning
and i got a job as the junior junior
team maker at publicis advertising
agency
ra and that i now call my sort of
university of
life um and then my mum got me in the
car and we went to pick up my a level
results
where i thought up until about a year
ago i got a d
in business studies i actually got an e
and
that was just ironic because that was
the moment
i started work i celebrated my 18th
birthday in the office
and i've been working ever since i'm 44
now and
so i think that that says a lot about
who i was i was just so eager to be in
the big
wide world um i remember my parents
going on holiday
and i was living at home and i mean
again if my son ever did this to me
i just um rented a place with some
friends in halston
because i was working um in in bake
street
um and just moved out i just packed up
the car and drove the car
and text my parents to say mom dad i've
moved out um
i'm living in holston which they weren't
necessarily
thrilled about um at what age i must
have been 18 yeah
18. um so
that is how that has been me i was
dyslexic didn't find out
um for my exams i am
definitely someone who has to work hard
to achieve um and always been creative
so that has been a constant in my life
i studied art uh at a level
and i created this huge sculpture that
they had never
had someone do before called tom dick
and harry
and they actually cast it in bronze and
had a crane pull it out of the
art studio and had to take the windows
out and that it's still
there today at my school um because i
i always go for it i suppose um
so yeah that was me you know but i'm so
when we say before the age of 18
you know i was in an office at the age
of 18. um all my friends went to uni
um and as i said i did this university
of life thing
um that work ethic was it at all
influenced by your parents when you say
you're excited by life but
was there an example set by your parents
about work ethic
um i think you know i was always
fascinated by my father's
role he was a financial a cfo at general
electric
and he traveled the world and i was
always fascinated with what he did
my grandparents all had you know their
own businesses
and i was fascinated by that my mother
had a small business
um when i was younger i think that
always
you know how we get our money was always
placed
um we didn't have you know
we weren't we were fine
but money and where we got our money was
always spoken about
so i i very quickly realized you work
to live so that's what happens and so
if i wanted to go out i needed to work
for that money
so that has just that was always part of
me
so you know maybe that just led to me
just continuing to work
because that meant that you lived and um
so yeah so i i think that but my work
ethic you know again
we were talking off air you know i give
it my my all
you know i lose myself in my work um it
is me
and so that's an interesting thing as
you get older so you you work at
publicist until you're 20 years old
i i yes i worked there until i was about
21 years old and then i
got head-hunted to move to conde nast uh
meantime i managed to marry my childhood
sweetheart
again uh hurricane holly was in a hurry
uh so
i bought a place i got married um
i need some more context here so your
childhood sweetheart you met him when he
was
we were 14 14 yeah yeah okay you're both
14. yeah
yeah and we got married uh at 21
and um divorced by 24.
and so it was an incred my early 20s
were a very very difficult period of
time of my life because
i had built up since i was 18. you know
i had built up this life in this world
and of course you get married then right
and you know you're gonna have children
and you've got a property
in chiswick and you know you're all
there
and then sort of life pays you back or
gives you i don't say pay you back
that's the wrong way gives you an
interesting lesson
which is be careful to be in a hurry all
the time just because you want it
and you can get it doesn't mean it's
right and so
we found ourselves as natural human
beings developing in our personalities
and things
and realizing that we weren't destined
to be together forever
um meantime i was diagnosed with a brain
tumor
and that was fine it wasn't fatal um but
it had a lot of side effects so at
quite a young age at sort of 23 24-ish i
was
dealing with a lot full-time job um all
these sorts of things and i again i look
at my son who's about to turn 17
i think all right wow holly you were
young
to do all of this so in my early 20s a
lot of things changed for me
um and i had to slow down i had to
lose full-time work i had to become
freelance i had to concentrate on my
health i had to
get divorced um and so yeah and that was
the first
knockdown i would say i've had two of
those in my life um
and that was the first one and it was
pretty painful
you find out at 20 through 24 years old
that you've got a brain tumour
how did you find that out i was just
very poorly
i put on a lot of weight and
i was uh just not functioning correctly
and
in the end um with all pushing it
because also also a young girl going to
the doctor and
pushing it with all the scans we found
out but as i said it was
it was livable with and um you know and
that's something
that's fine um but it caused just a huge
amount of turmoil and um that's not to
say i think
my marriage would have ever lasted
anyway but it just created turmoil
and i now think back to how tough your
early 20s are
you know i don't think i would repeat
them um i think it's quite a difficult
age you're meant to be grown up you're
just still a kid i'm trying to work
everything out at the same time yeah
absolutely well especially you the
situation you'd put yourself yeah
exactly
exactly yeah but you just think the
world's against you
and now i just realized it was a it was
a great kick up the butt
and so you go into freelance work you're
you're separated from this partner
you've learned the lessons there
hopefully yeah um you've understood the
situation with your health
yeah you didn't have to have an
operation no no you couldn't have one no
yeah i was i asked that particular
question because i actually found out
last week that one of my one of my best
friends has a brain tumor
and i and i was intrigued by the array
of emotions
that you felt in that moment and i asked
that question from a supportive
friend standpoint as how you support
someone that's
that's um found that out i think she's
24
24 and she found out that she found out
two weeks ago that she's having she had
a brain tumor and they put her into
an operation the next tuesday wow
because of the severity of the situation
so she's just come out of the
operation last night oh i really wish
her well i mean mine wasn't
you know it wasn't that serious so you
know that was something that
um i was very very lucky about
but i think one of the things was is
that i had to
find you know twice in my life i've had
to find out who i am again
because when you pull your identity into
something
else that's not yourself or or it
becomes your identity
i think we all do that in relationships
sometimes you know that you are
married or you know that's what i did as
a young girl
so then when it all fell apart who who
who am i and that was a really
difficult moment for me and slightly the
thing that saved me was going back to my
creative roots you know
if i hadn't gone to the university of
life i was going to go and do an art
degree
so creativity sort of saved me and i i
went on to
you know create vegetable wreaths which
again i just always think
you know the story needs to be sexier
than the vegetable race but there it was
and i i built this wreath and i went
down to my local high street to try and
sell it and i was just freelancing at
that time in publishing
but this was allowing me to be creative
in the evening why vegetable wreaths
though
um you know it it was just i needed to
be creative i love
i love interiors and i've always you
know at the age
my 14th birthday present was a
subscription to the world of interiors
um so you know that has just been
something i have to have a creative
environment
to exist in so my home right now as a
shrine to not on the high street i had
to move house to get bigger and bigger
homes
just to hold what you know you can
imagine
um what i'm surrounded by and so um
that was just glorious for me you know
why not um
i just did it and then that was this
path that just opened up to me because
i realized that i needed to sell these
things because i was going to obviously
become a millionaire
you know for reinventing the wreath
because that's what need was needed in
the world
and i realized that actually there
wasn't any local fare that i could go
and sell it so again
if you dream it up you can make it
happen so i created the first chizz at
christmas fair with 200 stalls so that i
could get the best store
you say that like it's so simple because
a lot of people
a wouldn't even they would have had the
reef idea and never done anything about
it
and then when they realized that they
couldn't sell it anywhere they would
have never done anything about that as
well
but there's clearly something that
underpins that perspective that okay
well that doesn't exist so i can create
that and yeah well that doesn't exist
i'll create that to support that that's
my dna
that's what i'm doing now holly and
coats what i did at notton high street
i don't just because it doesn't exist
doesn't even bother me it's actually
just part of the fun of building i'm i'm
i love building i love it about the risk
um well what risk because
um you know what was going to go wrong
there people weren't going to come to
the fair
i knew that they would i knew that
they'd like my wreaths because they were
good
i didn't see risk you know i i
i just went into it and i created this
event and it
kicked off it was amazing sold all my
wreaths
hated wreaths by the end of the thing
was not going to have that career but
now i was going to have a fair
career i was going to put on events so i
quit my job
um and told my dad who's my
be my cfo not in the high street and his
cfo at holly
and co and just said right that's what
i'm now going to do and so i delivered
all the wreaths got rid of that out of
my household
and i then um created these events
and put on 20 events around london
with small businesses and that was
almost
you know again a pretty bad existence
because i was on my own putting on these
events it was
you know pouring with rain one day you
can't control the weather you can't
control the football being changed you
can't do anything
but what it did do is it made me realize
um my total love
for small businesses and what they
create because i curated
all of those stalls and i could see
that there was absolute hidden treasure
that no one else had
discovered before and so the town hall
roof i suppose was the prototype
to not on high street i want to i want
to
go back to something you said a second
ago which was about that moment where
you kind of lose orientation your
marriage has ended because i just think
so many people listening to this
either have gone through that are going
through that or are going to go through
that moment where they have a
significant life change
which completely makes them unanchored
from what their like
purpose is and who they are and um
i'm fascinated by how long that process
lasted for you
and what advice you'd give to someone
who because i experienced it a little
bit when i like left my business
or actually the first time i experienced
it was when someone made me a really big
offer for my business
and then i went home that day and like
mentally spent the money and i thought
well then what who am i
yeah who now like yeah because your
whole identity was attached to this
business so you might say like
what advice would you have for someone
um that's going through that sort of
like loss of direction
because there's been a significant life
change and they they don't know
you know who they are or which way to go
anymore well it's actually something
that now i have a word for
um whereas at the time it was a sort of
process
when i consult with small businesses um
and i i don't now do one-on-ones but
um in my book for instance it's called a
brand heart
and it's basically i believe that a
business has a heart
and everything has to come off it
you know that's the pumping organ that
everything should
come back to now you as a founder need
to understand what should go into that
heart and it actually should be made up
of you
so i think what i did was i went back to
so what makes holly exist what makes
holly alive
and through that process which was about
a year
um and my second one which will come to
probably
you know lasted two or three years was
um creativity was one um discovering
um creative folk um my
the my community who was i meant to
belong to
um building entrepreneurism um
all these elements were coming through i
was lucky
um in my life at the end of the first
this year
i actually met my partner who's been my
partner for 18 years and i got married
and locked down so now he's my husband
um so i was lucky to find somebody
um and he did a lot of cheerleading for
me
you know sort of because when you're in
that place you don't
really um you don't have a perspective
on
anything that you can give anymore and
so i think that's another incredibly
important thing is to surround yourself
with people
who adore you and are willing to tell
you
what makes you um what makes the sun
shine out of you
you know what that is and so i was lucky
to have that
but that brand heart like the who is
holly
just cutting it up into five pieces and
say okay if there were five things i've
got to concentrate on
to bring to restore me what are they
um but it's a pretty painful process
what role does patience play from
in all of that process well none at the
beginning i mean
zero patience hurricane harley i mean do
you want to mean
now i've got a little bit more you know
actually i'm enjoying that getting older
and just having a slight
um listening more um
not running so fast um and picking up
the cues along the way
which i think i probably missed the
first time around so i'm actually really
happy
to become more patient i mean we'll put
it in perspective you know i'm
you know i i'm uh very ambitious so
but i am actually learning to listen um
to listen to the world a bit more
and even even though you've cut your
heart into five pieces there to dissect
who you actually are
um that doesn't necessarily mean you
know the
the path as in in terms of like the
business idea that's going to get you
get you there or the career but you you
know the fundamental principles of what
you're looking for yeah
and then what you need to do like
experiment do something yeah just
well actually that's not what i did for
not on the high street but it
is what we've done for holly and co
because um
that was the you know that's the point
isn't it you
learn i you know from not on the high
street holly and co i have learned i
don't want to do it all again
as i did but not in high street so i
don't want a final destination
when you take vc money on you have some
final destinations that you
you know you've turned right and not
left so always your course of direction
will be
to the right with holly and co what i
loved was
not not having that and also being able
to
um you know when people said so what is
holly and co
i could barely explain it i didn't have
an elevator pitch
i didn't want to fall into that actually
i think that is the beauty of what i
was looking to do but i did have a brand
heart i knew that we had that i didn't
have the final destination but i have
the coordinates of a few places i know
to go
and i know that i am you know i know the
direction i'm heading i always call it
like an anchor you know i've got an
anchor in the future
i've got the rope that i'm holding and
that rope will change
change it will pull me to the right and
left but i am anchored
um yeah and um and i'm enjoying that
that's what i'm really enjoying
so i've got a we've got to go through
this um this
uh not in the high street story because
i when i was reading
um about your journey up until this
point
and the experience you'd had in you know
working on you know creating a
a market or affair for for these small
businesses and then to go from there
to trying to create a e-commerce site
in the year that you did i thought was
just madness and i think about
entrepreneurs coming into the den and um
one of the questions i always ask them
is like have you got tech experience
yeah who's who's got the technical sort
of competence within the team show me
what you know
yeah and from looking at what your
journey opened to that point you didn't
have any of that stuff
yeah no none how beautiful is naivety
well yes delusion it is awesome
you know i look at it you know before
when i was in it
in it you know i thought oh my gosh
there's so many things that we need to
have done
before now i look at it and i think
could i just bottle up that naivety and
just take a swig of it
every single day you know naivety is the
thing if we had known
really that we were creating one of the
first marketplaces in the world you know
at that point in time
there was ebay and amazon amazon was
still selling books
ebay had you know your socks that you
got for christmas and the
you know the title was one two three
grandma's socks um
uh etsy hadn't launched yet um we
were basically looking at uh you know
like many businesses start a human
problem that we were experiencing and
thought we could
create a solution and all we needed to
do was take all those small businesses
that were under my town hall roof
and just put them on this thing called
the internet and then wouldn't it be
great if you could
shop from you know lily bell and shop
from the letter room and put it into one
basket
well of course okay well we got 20 grand
so let's
build a website for 20 000 pounds and we
found someone who could do that
big watch out there and funny enough
three days before launch
uh we realized that they couldn't do
that you know that there was no checkout
but because again there was no
experience we had already told the whole
world with a microsite that was counting
down the days to launch
and all the press that we were very able
to get
um that we were launching on this
specific day the third of april
so this 20 grand where did that come
from well the
the startup um that sophie and i had so
i i
uh the story is that basically after
your local fare had a three-month-old
boy called harry um with my now husband
frank
and i realized that i couldn't ignore
what i had witnessed when you put a
group of small businesses together that
are like-minded
and bring together discerning customers
there's something that happens there the
high street was dying
and i needed to do that but i knew i
didn't want to do it alone after your
local fare which was my fair business i
couldn't do it alone so i just wrote to
my old boss sophie
from publicis so she was my boss saying
you know
i basically don't think there's anyone
else on the planet that
has the into my yank you know is able to
rewrite the english dictionary
um and can be that person
and so i wrote to her and i still got
the email and it says
you know i want to bring everything
that's not on the high street
together but i had a terrible beater
name
and uh 24 hours later she said yes
because she
was that customer too she wanted to find
the curious
the discover the small businesses and
things but i had a three-month-old baby
that wasn't going to stop me and so we
went on this
journey to build it and as i said you
know we
tried to build a marketplace with no
tech experience or retail experience
but we knew what we wanted and so we
um pulled together a few savings
we were both with young children our
husbands were
working to pay for the mortgage um
we got a loan from a bank very small
loan and we remortgaged our homes
slightly both of us so i think we came
to it with about 80
000 pounds thinking that we had
contingency in there
i mean everything and funny enough
uh we didn't have enough money but we
launched
on the third of april with no check out
to our shopping site
um why was there no checkout well
because funny enough ebay couldn't even
build a
multi-partner checkout with one basket
you know
no one had yet actually done that
technology
so and i remember naively calling you
know
calling ebay just picking up the phone
to ebay thinking i don't know who i'm
going to get through to ebay hey hi is
that the cto you know that stuff you're
building there's any chance uh i could
have it too
because we're dealing with a company in
cornwall
who uh has led us down
um so we didn't you know this hadn't
been built yet this this this
functionality
and so we launched we called it a press
preview
and we just pivoted and we were uh
on something called daily candy which
was huge at the time we were on the
daily mail front cover
all this sort of stuff it was great so
we got all the traffic but no one could
check out
um but you know as mother lions that we
were
and i always liken businesses
to being a parent
something that in my latter years was
frowned upon
by the vcs because actually i do believe
that when you have that spirit of a
parent you can lift a car
off a child when you're a founder and
literally you're launching a shopping
site with no checkout what are you going
to do
and so we found someone who in two weeks
built the technology that ebay were
building in america
um and we just relaunched and and we
nailed it
did you run out of money in those early
yeah yeah
totally we ran out money we launched in
the april and we're running out of money
in the july
um because funny enough technology costs
a lot of money
especially when it's never been built
before and um
and so we had to go and raise money
and that was one heck of an experience
because if you want to take yourself
back to 2006
when we know one percent of vc money
right now goes to women what do you
think the statistic was
then so we would pack up our
personalized bags
we get on the tube no money for taxis we
would knock on the doors
with meetings you know that people knew
someone who knew someone
and we go and pitch the idea of not on
the high street to
the land of vcs who pretty much
a hundred percent would tell us that
their wives did the shopping
in their household and that it was
lovely that us women
wanted to create a crafts website but
really
there was nothing in it and i just said
well we're actually going to change the
face of retailing
funny enough it's not a craft website
and
that continued right up until the
christmas
and we were now paying our staff on our
egg credit card checkbooks we were my
parents remortgaged their house twice
uh sophie's parents uh lent us money i
mean it was
dark dark days i mean not in the high
street was definitely
on its last breath but the issue was it
was working
you know it hadn't been working up until
that point we used to have a bell that
you would ring
when there was a checkout of 30 pounds
and we were taking 10
and this bell would ring every second
day and we were just thinking my god
this is
just hell but just as we were really
running out of money
the bell just kept on ringing it was
happening because it was christmas and
people wanted
great gifts um so that was an
extraordinary journey
but one that ended well because we found
someone who understood what we were
building um
and by the february 2007 we got our
first
round of investment how long did that
take to find that person
so from when you realized you had to
start fundraising to the point when you
the money hit your bank let's say well
it must have been uh
eight months um but when we were
pitching it was just before christmas
and i remember just telling them we
hadn't got our first set of accounts yet
you know we were there and i remember
my father being in the pitch meeting
and um you know we were putting what we
were doing there
obviously avoiding the conversation that
we were paying the staff
with our credit card checkbooks you know
like
everything is fine oh my gosh that you
know it's like every time you raise any
money the graphs only go
you know through the sky and how you're
going to do it
will work it out but it was an amazing
moment and uh tom tightman who was the
investor had just written the first
check for lastminute.com
and he saw what we were trying to do and
he actually
saw the power of female uh female
purchasers
and that whole world and so um
we did the pitch and he he you know he
played with rc
he basically said that's great thank you
so much and we packed up and we left and
my father said i'm so proud of you both
knowing that not in the high street
just died that we hadn't got the money
and it was
finished because where our homes were on
the line it was
it was finished and just as we pressed
the bell for the elevator
he said actually do you have a moment
and he bought a bottle of champagne and
and that was it our destinies changed
but that was how
close we were um but you know we
definitely turned right that meant
we got our first vc fantastic and then
um you know we started building not on
high street and
it was growing very very quickly
was it ever going to fail in your view i
know you came close but was it ever
going to be not at all
never isn't that funny never never never
you know at the same time that we were
running out of money i was buying every
single euro
for the whole world so we couldn't pay
for the heating
so we had coats on between you know 9 am
and 2 that was the coldest period in our
office
and then the because the whole building
was being knocked down but we just kept
our office
so we had no boiler no heating but i was
still buying the urls
across the globe and and to this day
i think it's one of the most fantastic
businesses
um but never would it fail ever
because you know you as a parent you
know
if your child had any issue would you
not think that you could overcome those
issues
absolutely and that's the resolut
resolute that you need
to be in business it's why i call not in
high street my first business baby
holly and co my second i love them as if
they are my children
um and they will get my my full
attention
what is your favorite flavor of heel
jack
berry my favorite flavor of fuel is
banana berry used to be my favorite
flavor and i saw someone tweet the other
day they said
um because puel is now in tesco's but
the only flavor in tesco's is the
chocolate flavor
they were sort of demanding tesco's put
the um
the berry flavor in because that's
steve's favorite it's not my favorite
flavor is clearly banana now
those are the ones i look for the most
what does huel do for me i mean i've
talked about this extensively
but for me i get that a nutritionally
complete diet
in 60 seconds and in the world i live in
that is a that is a remarkable thing and
this is why
even before they became a podcast
sponsor i was buying heel to my office
um every single week you know and the
funny thing is jack who's the director
and producer of this podcast
he tried cure once he was like yeah yeah
the guy is addicted to hill he's a fiend
for you now because once you see the
impact it has you understand the
convenience you understand it's
nutritionally complete
for me it's life-changing and that's why
hula is a bit of a it's a bit of a
cult once you try it you can't go back
you just said there that you know the
company was completely out of money but
but i
i could tell that you also didn't
believe it would fail which is a
bit of a contradiction to some degree
but well because it was just money
yeah and you could you could figure that
out i don't know how yeah
but you know you know money is just this
you know okay so if we got the money and
the hard bit really is
doing the doing isn't it it's building
it so i always just knew
somehow this will work out i mean of
course you have your terrible dark days
but i knew it was going to work out how
could it not
were you on to something and i knew that
that level of optimism in upon
reflection of your career of the last
you know couple of decades how important
has that optimism
been that just like unexplainable
unjustifiable
i don't know why but it'll just it will
all work out optimism because you've
also because because you've employed a
lot of people seeing the opposite
that sense of like catastrophe you know
that catastrophizing oh no we're a
[ __ ] you know that kind of oh
yeah oh man i've i've kissed a lot of
those frogs
um yeah wouldn't you say that that's a
common denominator you find
in entrepreneurs 100 i mean even in team
members
someone so i've i it's so i say i can't
explain it enough
i one example i always come back to was
um
i was flying to brazil and obama was
speaking at the same time as me
um on the same stage as me just like i'm
speaking just after me
and i thought well obama's here i'm a
speaker he's a speaker
can't i meet him and someone that was
working for me at the time went oh no i
asked somebody and they said no
sick as a [ __ ] if they said no ask
someone else and just keep asking
and then they're like no no steve we've
been asking and they just said no so
i'll do it then and i
i sent some emails and within
30 uh within 30 emails someone comes and
grabs me goes come and meet obama
yeah and i just think there's always a
way there's always a way
and your life yeah and my life is
testament to this upset this like
there is a way or there's a way that's
you know what i mean
there's a way where i have to work
harder you know what i mean and i don't
i don't allow for this other outcome
which is that oh no we can't
i've never allowed for the other outcome
ever
and it's actually my entire battery is
powered by that
and i am told i radiate it
so when you're around me you get hooked
on to that
and that's can be a really good thing
because it drives people in those dark
days when
actually the entire world is telling you
no
and i'm saying yes and so
it's an amazing thing and i think that
optimism and actually
now as i said getting older it's
actually
i i would say there's optimism and now i
also have gratitude
that's powering my battery you know i
worked out my 40th birthday i have 29
000 days on this planet
because i'm and as another golden thread
that i'm sure you recognize as
efficiency
i'm freaking addicted to it so i needed
to know
so you know this life i just need to
schedule this a bit
so you know so i've got 29 000 days oh
[ __ ] it's not 29 000 days it's 14
000 days because i'm 40 right okay and
so
that has also led to a countdown till i
die
so that also has fueled this optimism
and and [ __ ] it mentality
because if today i am going to change
the world which i can
it's even fueled even in in a better way
actually i didn't have that
not in the high street because that was
just you know fire fighting and
optimum was that that that that fuel
but now i think i have gratitude
powering that even more and that's been
in a beautiful beautiful stage of my
life
that is amazing and you're right you so
you're you're in survival mode and now
you're
now you've got choice now i've got
choice and
a bit of you know the battle scars are
there and
i have an appreciation that you know i
can give everything and
all but i need to make sure that my time
on the planet
is also for me too because i do believe
i'm here to serve
and i've again i can only say that now
in hindsight
but if i am here to serve i need to also
serve myself
that sense of by the way i completely um
resonate with
this um this focus on the amount of time
we have left i wrote about it in my book
at very
long length and you i think somewhere
behind me there's a little sand timer
somewhere on there there's usually a
sound timer i don't know it seems to
walk around but because i wrote about it
in my book at such length people started
buying sound timers
and and uploading them online and the
whole point of the sound timers it's one
of the things that really allows me
it reminds me of time it's like one of
the ways we can see time happening
just by turning it you see your life
moving away
and it's that important reminder just
like get on with it and focus on what
matters
you mentioned um you now feel like
you're here to serve
do you think that comes from
understanding your own power
yeah i think so i think so i
i would have found that really difficult
to tell you
20 years ago but now um
i have been through it and done it
and i also know that my optimism helps
people
and i can see the effects and i can see
you know what we
brought up and not in the high street
was full of it you know i used to have
people come in to the
office um from other businesses that we
would hire
they literally could feel it in the air
they were uncomfortable with it
it was optimistic it was creative it was
emotional
and they were like this place is so
emotional and i'm like yeah
and they're like uh we need to stop that
and i'm like
we're never stopping that and i think
that that's
what i've realized is that that is what
i can muster up you know i
i listen to one of my favorite songs is
cloud busting by kate bush
and when i listen to that song i feel
like i'm whipping up a storm
and that is my power but what i try and
whip up
is very positive and good for the soul
good for small businesses good for and
what are small businesses they're
founders with dreams you know
i love that and so um
that is why i've writ potentially that
is now
my job description um for the rest of my
life
is to build something that i can pour
that in
and be efficient and so amplify it so
not build an empire
but be really smart and amplify that
feeling
out to other people and help them
there's an irony in that that you're
talking about whipping up a storm and
your nickname's hurricane holly
yeah actually i've never even said that
before and so yes i like that link that
just happened there
slightly different meaning now it's not
necessarily about urgency and more about
i guess just
power but yes exactly yeah yeah two
different weather
types yeah yeah so take me back so that
you start
not on the high street it starts moving
you've got the vc money things
you know team is small things are agile
typically the most fun times yeah yeah
the team was small um myself sophie
i hired my sister um who was just going
to help me out for a summer
uh she still works for me at holly and
co so that's been a good
16 17 years that we've worked together
now um
hired then her university friend her
university friend came and coded the
site
that but you know it's that beautiful
moment that you're just literally do you
have a pulse and do you breathe
okay would you like to come and work for
us you know i was talking to somebody
the other day
um and he said it's that wonderful
naivety where you get in a car in the
cab and the taxi driver is really really
chatty
and so you almost go and offer them a
job because it's just
this moment where you need soldiers you
know that's that time isn't it
you don't need the skill we need power
and
um we need energy and we need commitment
and we need you not to have a high
salary
that's the that's that moment in time
and so that was what it was and you know
we were growing at 2 000
we were trying to keep up with it i call
it like that speed train with all the
nuts and bolts of flying off and you're
you're at the driving seat and there
you're going
and as you said with optimism that
energy is just infectious
and so we just were growing
so rapidly so we were going from
a hundred thousand pounds ttv to
a million the next year to two and a
half million
to six million now keeping up with that
and also remember
in a marketplace you have two clients
yeah i always laugh at people that
moan about having one client like try to
you know you've got
your customers and you've got all the
small businesses which by the way
you are only as great as their ability
to keep up with 2 000 growth
some of them are growing at 5 000
because they're the hot product
and so it's that coaching of that group
of people to keep
up with you meanwhile you know the swan
to the customers and the swan to the uh
partners which we called them partners
from day one you know they weren't
sellers we were only as great as they
they were
and that was that beautiful shift that
we were creating in this world
we were we were respecting small
businesses they would get a media pack
that cost us way too much i think about
five pounds per thing
but we wanted them to know how talented
they were
we curated from day one which now
you know uh is a word we use a lot back
then
it was not a word you know why aren't
you accepting everybody
and we would be no we're turning away 90
percent of everyone that joins even
though they're paying adjoining fee and
we're eating baked beans and worrying
about the mortgage
we're not getting paid a salary we will
turn away 90
because one day our brand will thank us
for it
and it did it very very much did
you talk there about hiring and that
flipping hiring process at the start
which i know very well and i i've joked
about on this podcast before like
walking into pride and the guy selling
the bags was like jonathan a director i
was like yeah
and then like i had some guy on facebook
he's called ash one of my good friends
now and he even laughs about it he was
on job seekers allowance he'd never done
a job in his life
i made a marketing director and i was 18
and i was just like [ __ ] it you know
like
yeah but you're like what's the worst i
don't think i think this could work
out right imagine if it does work out
that the taxi driver
is going to be amazing funny enough
it doesn't necessarily work out that way
almost never
so but it's just i think the interview
process when you're that naive is
literally would you work for me
and they go yep fine you've got the job
yeah or is there salary
low enough that's actually double bonus
yeah
yeah absolutely yeah it's it's a crazy
thing the hiring process has been
again on reflection something i'm
learning right now to do
is that would probably be one of the
most beautiful points of building holly
and co is my team and investing
heavily in the development of each one
of the souls that i think
are life is with me now not on the high
street it was the soldiers you needed
the energy and then you get into the
next stage don't you where
actually those people by very nature
can't stay with the business because now
you need skill
and there's that awful moment where
you're having to let people go for the
first time
and bring in skill and to bringing skill
you now need to interview don't you and
you now need to be able to know even
what the skill is that you're even
looking for
as you're running at 200 miles an hour
and then it goes into that's next stage
where you're now looking for the people
to run the people
who you've just hired you know and that
process for me
was not something i could spend enough
time on i mean we interviewed
absolutely everybody until the point
that we had a c-suite
and um i always remember my father
saying
that 90 of my role as ceo
should have been the people
90 of my role was not the people because
how on earth could it be
i mean you know you were the next race
was happening or we were going
international or
you know we've decided to double the
company in a year
and now on reflection when i look at
that oh
it's the people so with holly and co
i've now got a good group of people
that i believe are life as and i'm happy
to say that because what i
believe is that they don't even know how
great they are and i'm going to shine
their diamond
until it completely shines and that's
dealing with their personal side
that's dealing with their professional
skills that's dealing with their whole
self
um and that is something i'm fascinated
by
and i think i'm potentially going to
build one of the most incredible teams
um that i've ever
been lucky enough to manage and you've
learned those people i just everything
you said then i'm not i just agree with
it all
i agree with every single word because i
went through the same exactly the same
journey of
hiring anybody bringing in skill
bringing in a bunch of people that had
done this job for 20 years to tell me
what to do and i got out the way
and i let them run the team and do all
the hiring for me but then i also had
the reflection three four years in that
in fact this whole time what i actually
was was a recruitment company
and that was my sole responsibility yeah
and then you look at all the people
there and you
go to the kitchen that i i would and i
would
you'd be getting a cup of tea and i
wouldn't know the person to my left
how terrible is that and also that you
realize when you get that c-suite in
because that's what we need to do
because we've now got vcs and we need to
get the
the huge company cos and the cfos and
all the seas
um i call it um in
that they just then recruit the carbon
copies of themselves
so suddenly you've got an entire
organization of many
you know of those people and actually my
gosh suddenly
the pendulum swings so for not in the
high street remember
we always used to say you know we've got
our marketplace hat on one day
so that is about trading the site and
understanding what customers need and
then we've got our retail hat on
which is the brand because we're not in
the high street we're not ebay we're not
amazon
we are not on the high street we are
that beautiful mix
because we know our customer and so
that was very interesting because
actually what you need and require
to be able to curate unique products and
unique companies
is creativity eyeballs taste
all these things that are unable to
excel you cannot put you know
many times i've been asked can you just
please tell me the process between a and
z
of a great product and i'm like you see
you even asking me that my dear
means that you don't even understand
what makes a great knot in the high
street product
so that was the difficulty is that
suddenly you would get too much of the
processing
too much of the operations everything
was a meeting
everything was a powerpoint everything
and that room for creativity and life
and entrepreneurial spirit
started being pushed to the side and
that was a very difficult period in time
you know
we were you know still growing so
incredibly quickly
um so it was a difficult moment to try
and balance
that state of growth and tech issues and
operational issues and funny enough hr
issues when you have enough people
um with that need
to be what i call truffle hunters now
you know people that can
really find the most unique amazing
small business that will create
the next bestsellers did you find
yourself at war with the business you
created
um
i i loved it so again if i look at being
a parent
i loved it but i didn't enjoy them right
now
you know i found them difficult to live
with
you know and that's what i would say
it's you never lose your love
you never lose the but actually what was
happening
was the process had become so big
that the core of what i loved
founder titus you know the duracell
battery
you know that is why founders are
unbelievable
should never be moved from a business
whatever should maybe take a new role
that's okay because actually they don't
enjoy the role of the operations
but that sort of duracell battery when
you take it out of a business
you know it i'm sure you've interviewed
many people that you
something goes the customer even knows
it everyone knows it
and so that was that's just been a
brilliant uh
lesson for me but also a lesson that i
now pass on
through holly and co you know holly and
co is all about me being vulnerable with
the truth
and hopefully inspiring other people
that when they're growing their small
business and they think they're going to
hire the next person that's going to be
the silver bullet a
there is zero silver bullets in business
but b
it doesn't work without you you know for
all your defects and all your faults and
all your weaknesses it just doesn't work
without you
and was there a moment where you
realized that you'd have to take a
different role
within the business yeah i suppose it
got to that point where
um 200 people five vcs i was chairwoman
and ceo um and
things were changing you know i was
you know 15 meetings a day running to
the loo
with my pa who would then brief me as i
was in the loo
on my next meeting to go into my office
where it was already set up
to be countlessly doing board meetings
you know one board mini
team would finish and we'd be preparing
for the next board meeting
um and basically being
at at a stage where
in any given day did i do anything
that i loved you know my new book is do
what you love love what you do you know
i brought up this business that i loved
but every single day did i actually ever
do
what i loved and there was that moment
where i needed to make that decision
um and it was a pretty
goddamn painful one where i sort of
realized i'd lost myself
you know i was um i didn't look like i
looked today you know i was in the tube
dress
with the high heels on double spanx on
i was a she man you know i needed to be
that person i was brought up remember i
was 28 when i started i was i was
brought up through not on the high
street and experience
that's all my reference point was and so
i knew i needed to
dull motion and you know drive this and
be
this person and um and i think i was
probably in reflection tired
of not being holly
could you feel it yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i didn't know at the time like you
were just saying i was just in the
motion i was a hamster in the wheel
you don't know any different you know
you just exist don't you and
your whole purpose is to fuel everybody
else and sort of you
you realize that when you're not there
things go off the rails and so
you have this sense of responsibility
and every night i went to sleep
um i would lay on my pillow i would have
my son
as my responsibility i would have my
home i was the main breadwinner
of our home but i would have the
thousands of small businesses that if i
go wrong ever you know a lot of them 50
of them relied on that this was their
only income their husbands had quit
their job you know they were doing
million pounds two million pounds a year
like
this was my responsibility and the staff
were my responsibilities i had
this heaviness so how could i be light
holly
how could i smile or laugh i you know i
i found
myself becoming a different version of
me
um one of the lines at holland co is
bringing colour to grey
and i think i was turning grey did your
partner know that frank
yeah yeah you know definitely knew that
we were in a catch-22 though you know
when you bring up a business
that's providing the only income there's
no way out you know
how how does this go somewhere because
my ambition
you couldn't stop me i was on the
hamster wheel i could see everything you
know i always
have to be reminded what year i'm in
because i can see what the future is
i know what it is so why i just need now
need to make it happen that's the
the part so you know we we nearly didn't
survive a few times
during that um time you know being an
entrepreneur and having a relationship
is a very very difficult thing
because and having a young child you
know harry was three months old when i
started not
if the nanny didn't arrive he was put
under my desk
you know i remember at the age of two he
was under my desk he had a dvd player
you remember where you actually put the
dvd and you open the screen and you put
the headphones on
what sits in ribena and i would just
sort of shuffle
them in there and there used to be a
program called mr british where she
used to talk about putting the baby in
the drawer when mr president that was
what harry was he was under the thing
because
being a woman and a mother no you know
the kid doesn't come to work even though
i was the boss
but it was their mindset no we are tech
female entrepreneurs we have got to be a
certain
way um and so that was very challenging
and it puts a strain on relationships um
and so that has just been difficult you
know
you know the downs are very down dark
dark days when you're running out of
money
you've got to raise again but the
business is going amazingly
you have no choice let's do it again um
and
you know your family takes a toll and
that decision to
sort of change your role that's not a
decision that's made overnight that's a
slow sort of grinding down and other
conversations up until that point with
the board and with
other people and with frank or yeah
there was i mean
it was a bit of a storm of lots of
things i can't quite
remember what was going on at that point
in time but it was you know
another christmas was coming up it's
going to be double what that
is coming in um a very full c-suite
managing that group of people um
being at you know now vcs are really
waking up you know what we're doing
where you know i think we were at 100
over 100 million ttv
you know this was starting to become
something it was about
internationalization so doing it all
again but in other countries
and um there was just this point that
that
needed to probably not be my existence
in the future
so um ripped off the plaster
and did it and decided to get a
seasoned ceo to come and replace me
um sophie had left the business at this
point a few years before
so i was why uh her children were at a
different stage of life
um were older than harry so again as a
mother
it's okay when they're little and she
gave me that great advice you know
don't worry you've missed his first
steps he won't remember
but when they're doing their jesus
season a-levels they freaking need
mom and um and so
she you know i realized that i was
again i thought i could do it all and i
i just
now in hindsight in my father had left a
cfo
two years before that so i was sort of
on my todd
i was now this woman with this group
with these feces and um
you know you're always plagued with the
imposter syndrome and i think that
i allowed that to ha you know
determine a few things in my life now i
look back thank goodness for that
because what i'm doing today i have
never
felt more powerful i've never felt more
holy i've never felt more
colorful i've never felt more of a
founder than i do today
and i'm in complete control
but when we go back to the story of the
two times in my life that i lost my
identity
might i not rip the plaster off if i'd
known what i was going to go through
because i'm sure you've had people
describe it it is not funny
losing leaving your business if we
relate it to a child
how does a mother walk away from his kid
you know talk to me about that process
yeah it's a very very hard one i think
actually
so many more people need to talk about
it because i think it's like a bit of a
dark secret like
it's it's that thing we're all bound by
certain things
all this sort of um our ego is at play
here
you know there's so many our shame are
all those points and i i wish
more founders spoke about this moment
it's your entire identity goes now now i
had built
i was just you know hi what do you do
i'm the ceo of not on the high street
really you know uh when you wake up in
the day
it's all those emails it's all it's all
that responsibility
the pressure on your shoulders wake up
the next day
what do you do um
you just forget to even say you found
not you know you were the founder of
norton high street you're but you're
nothing
so i had a couple of years that were
maybe two three years
two years dark years where you know at
stages i couldn't get out of bed
um but you know when i had to do it all
again
you know i had to look at my brand heart
i had to surround myself with people
who could raise the phoenix out of the
ashes
um but it was difficult you know i i
couldn't go
to events with small businesses i would
you know break down i would have to
leave
i i couldn't see people that i knew
i i couldn't meet socially with people
because i just didn't know who i was
um and it was just a very difficult time
in my life
how old were you at this this time well
i must have been
uh 39
no forty fourteen and what you're
describing there in terms of symptoms
sounds
like depression that phase is actually
what i think it is sounds like is
um what what i think now i think it is
is grief
grief yeah i went through i went through
the seven stages of grief
i um it really was a loss
you know that was what i was and
especially as i'd always likened it to
my child you know i had harry my real
baby
and i had not nice street now i wasn't
with my second baby
so how can a mother do that to start
with
what happens when i'm not there it's
going to fall and i'm not going to be
there to pick it up
so it was a very very difficult process
but as i said you know
i went through total grief i i i got
counselling
i surrounded myself with great people
i instantly had to start building you
know it was the only thing i knew
in my head um so six months
later i my sister
uh was employed by norton high street
she left someone else left who's now my
other co-founder and we would sit around
my kitchen table
um i decided to ditch the heels so i
threw away every single pair of high
heels i owned
um today i'm wearing glitter trainers
and i have done for five years
to really say that actually you can be a
very powerful knowledgeable business
woman
and wear glitter trainers and actually
this is holly
and so slowly i started peeling the
spanx off
the heels i slowly started rediscovering
who holly was
i had some cheerleaders around me who
would remind me on the darkest days
and i knew that creativity like it had
done with the vegetable reese
was there as my savior what i
had to be is holly again and holly is
only holly i think
with a business within her you know uh
and
when i say business and what i'm trying
to rediscover with holly and co
and trying to put it out there is
actually it's not just business
i believe creating a business makes you
happy
and actually um striving for happiness
i think that when you can control your
own destiny you can
work around your family when you can be
your most creative self
when you can answer to nobody when you
can dictate all of these things where
you live what you do
that is a real source of going for
happiness and
so actually people do ask me why are you
freaking obsessed with business holly
like
redefining business what is it about
business i'm like it's not about
business business is a tool and a key
business is just the thing the vehicle
to get all these other things and that
is why holly and co sort of had to exist
i did say to my husband never again
you know because he couldn't do what i
mean it's huge the whole family goes
through
your storm you're whipping up but
my yeah
yeah oh yeah but when you give them
enough glasses of wine
and you can sell anything to anybody you
can definitely tell them
so my sisters uh carrie my actual sister
gabby who left not in the high street
and has become almost like an adopted
sister but with the founders of holly
and co
they basically said you can't ignore
your bird's eye point of view that you
had that is unique to not in the high
street
you saw thousands upon thousands of
businesses
grow from nothing to where they are
today
because all i was obsessed with was the
common denominators the
they all felt alone and yet they were
going through the same thing
and i remember when we built not in the
high street
naively i thought we could have a
consumer site
but i knew very quickly that they would
need a b2b site because as they were
growing
they would need the tools so i said to
myself well we'll build two sites when
we launched norton high street
obviously that didn't happen um
now that b2b site was on the agenda not
in the high street every year
for 11 years and uh actually now i think
that holly and co
is my b2b scratch that i've itched
but when you talk about business
normally it's done in a certain way in a
2d way
in a greater way and my plight was to
help the dreamers we have a phrase dream
dabble do
at holly and co i want to help the
dreamers become doers and i want to help
the dreamers
go for it and i want to help the doers
never give up
and so that means you need to give
business a facelift
and so that is what i'm trying to do is
create a bubble
an existence for these small businesses
to live in
where i sort of with the my knowledge
have
created a world where i answer the needs
you know
you don't need to have a business plan
you need to have a plan
you know one day you might need to have
a business plan to raise money
but you need to have a plan and the
second you take that you pop that
balloon people start coming alive
and so that is why holly and co
was where my sisters say you can't
ignore that and that was the moment
holly do you know how much knowledge you
have in your head that you need to share
and there's the this of service part
that came through
and i think as i rose from those ashes
as my wings became colorful
service was written on my back and that
has
now allowed me to put myself out there
as quite a private person but because
i'm of service
it doesn't matter what i feel it's what
i can do for others
and that has just been the again that's
the fuel in my duracell battery that
just gets me up every single day
quick one i've recently made a purchase
i've bought myself a tesla cyber track
it's not here yet
they're still not to be delivered and
the reason i decided to do that i sold
my range rover sport and i ordered a
tesla cyber truck was because i want the
vehicle that i drive to be
run purely on sustainable energy and
that's also why we were so keen to have
my energy become a partner in this
podcast so we can
start talking about sustainable energy
and one of the great pioneering products
that my energy have created
is this thing called the zappy which is
so discreet fits on the outside of your
home
and allows you to charge a huge list of
electric cars
including my cyber truck so when my
cyber truck comes
i'm going to put this on the outside of
my house and this
will charge it which i think is just
amazing this is britain's
number one best-selling solar ev charger
and it's beautiful and i can't wait for
my cyber truck to come just so i can
have a play with this
you refer to holly and coz being a good
life business
yeah well i i referred to it being a
good life business but
i also want to abolish the word sme
you know i think that there's a whole
new language that even needs to come
into business
um and i'm not talking about businesses
who want to float on the stock exchange
i'm not talking about tech businesses
i'm talking about 99.9
of all um businesses in the uk are small
and medium right i'm talking about that
when the founders sat around a kitchen
table in their slippers
and has come up with a great idea now
they find themselves with 50 people i
want to always remind them that they
were the founder
with slippers with that crazy idea and
that i
hear them and i see them and i feel them
and i want to create something for them
so the good life it sounds very personal
because um i
really you know i'm of service i care
about people enormously
you know if i feel emotional when i talk
about it
um i want them to have the best life
that they can have
and i i really would live in gratitude
because i'm experiencing it and i want
others to
and i think i could be the key so
that is my power and so one of the
things i say to people is you know
they're not comfortable calling
themselves entrepreneurs
they don't want to be an sme hi my
name's julia and i'm an sme
they don't want to you know so i say you
look you run a good life company
you balance your creativity and your
need to drop off the kids
and pick them up and have family life
and take august off right
with your ambition profitability growth
and your own little empire building you
know those are the two things that you
balance
and that's a good life you're not
looking to get nekkar island at the end
you've already and what i always say to
people is have you ever looked at where
you want to be when you're 80.
you know it's a lot of people don't by
the way no one
so if you want to be in your business
you know right now my son's working at
hollyon coast training as a barista
you know he was three months old he's
nearly 17.
he towers above me as this strong man
that i thought i was going to [ __ ] up
definitely as a baby i'm so proud of him
he has his own business
you know that is the good life i have
brought up the next generation that
needs to understand entrepreneurism
do i i want to exist in a world where he
could be by my side in the future
where these group of this team that i've
got can work with me for 20 years
where my husband where i take fridays
off and i go on a date with my husband
that's what my good life looks like and
so
that is where you know i can see myself
at 90 here
but i do ask people have you looked at
the future because you by looking at the
future understanding that last point
you can work backwards because it's
normally not all the riches the
lamborghini
the the you know all that thing that we
we we
see don't we sunday times rich list you
know is that
is that really where we're heading or is
it a world where our mental health is
stable
we're with our family for as much as we
can get when our health is good
um where we're creatively fulfilled
we're changing the world even if it's
just your town
you're doing something and um and that
is why now people call themselves a good
life business
and that requires as you say like a real
change in narrative because
instagram and that external voice is
telling you
build hire more people make more money
and and what i love about what you've
said there as well is you you're
you're centering so a lot of the when
you ask
a business um or their objective is a
lot of them
will fall into the trap of and simon
sinek talks about this saying we want to
be
the best or number one and just at the
very end of my time at my business
i stood in front of all of my employees
in the office and said and explained why
um
why we we had to remove that terminology
from all of our
um from all of our internal and external
comms because
um those it views
life in our journey as a um
a finite game like we'd get to the
number one on the scoreboard but then
what then
and if and because there's nothing then
once you're number one or you're big or
you've made whatever there's nothing
then
we try and shift the company towards a
direction where we viewed it as like an
infinite game where
um there isn't a scoreboard and we're
trying to create a sustainable life for
ourselves
and our company that could theoretically
last for many many many decades
and when you start viewing your business
and your employees in that way that they
might that they could be here for
30 years all of your decisions are
different
and your goals are different but it's
tough when you have vcs of course
of course and so that's it's impossible
and that's what you you then
you know you're a chameleon aren't you
and so you
you will behave a certain way
so with holly and co that's the
liberation i have
where i understand the value of raising
someone up to the highest point of their
lives
personally and professionally they are
rock stars they've never and they
they know that holly and co was the
reason for that they were set free of
anything they asked and they're going to
be there for 20 years and they're going
to grow
so many businesses neglect history as a
really
really valuable tool you know what
you've done before and what has worked
and hasn't worked is
incredibly important um i actually do
value the the um the want for people
to become um sort of the
the champions i suppose and so
that is now the destination why i don't
have the elevator pitch
i mean who am i pitching to you know
what why i don't have the destination i
have an anchor
that anchors my 90th birthday i have an
anchor which is my vision
but i don't have to define it yet
because i want to be around for that
long and how on earth we know as an
entrepreneur
you don't you can't tell me what's going
to happen next year you know we we ca
we can have a course we have her best
intentions and we can think that these
people are going to be the a game
um and so that has been the beautiful
point and that is the knowledge i'm
trying to share with this community
trying to help them understand that
they're not
a cookie-cutter business they don't need
to be they shouldn't be
um and that that's what i'm hopefully
leading by example
for me a really pivotal point and what
you're saying there was either we had
this guy in my business who used to ask
this really annoying question when we
were growing
he should say um but yeah what's like
the purpose of social chain
and he was just asking me that question
like what's the what's the what's our
purpose what's our purpose and i thought
he was a bit
a bit of an irritant because we're
trying i'm just trying to keep this
thing alive
purpose is paying you yeah it's making
sure i can
make payday this month then next month
and that was my purpose yeah
but they got to a point where i did
start to reflect maybe five years in on
like
what what is this what am i doing this
for
um and that's when i went away that i
think it was a christmas time
and i and i sat down and said what is
the what is the purpose of this company
and i came up with this www.thing where
i was like um
work welfare in the world these kind of
three components so
the work we do and the standard of work
we do for our clients and
i broke that down into a set of goals
and values uh welfare was really about
the team and the family that were
working here
and then the world was the wider impact
that we have because of our existence on
the outside world
and again that broke down into a set of
goals and objectives about the
environment and about philanthropy
and that gave us all this kind of www
dot set of values and meaning in the
world
and that's the thing that pushed me
towards realizing that i had to make a
company that was sustainable one not
that one
not one that was driven for the stock
market i
had lost control of the company because
there was
i owned a small percent by this stage
there was
board members that were triple my age
i was still the ceo but a lot of it's
lip service when you don't really have
control
right they want they need to keep you
happy because you have a lot of
influence over a lot of things um but i
couldn't steer the company in the
direction i wanted to and
you have different objectives there's a
lot of people
95 of people in the board are trying to
make money just more and more money
by any means necessary and you're trying
to be this founder that's got these
dreams and visions of beauty
and talking about purpose and values
yeah and it
it's just nonsense in that environment
and i realized
that's why i resigned last year i
realized that the way that i wanted to
take the business in was not possible
i no longer had that control because
starting at 21 giving up that control
you can't get it back
you can't and now you you have got the
war scars you've got the battle scars
and then what's so fascinating and i'm
excited for you
is whatever's next you've had those hard
lessons
and potentially what you'll build next
is going to be your good life company
where you can start resetting some of
those things
rewiring for yourself and we're lucky to
be able to do it again
you know that's the amazing thing
but you know it's never do you care
still about the business
um it's still my baby like
i remember i saw someone on a competitor
on linkedin the other day just like
they had like um they'd paid to
take us our name on um seo oh yes yeah
yeah you're just like oh you were really
looking for serious chamber
and i was looking at the new [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then you're
almost like who's not looking at that
yeah yeah you wanted to call someone yes
why is
yesterday there was a tweet on social
chains twitter and i was like and i i
posted to the managing director of the
us i'm like yeah
someone needs to step in here and
clarify and i literally took a
screenshot i'm like i would
if i was there if
you know it's it's a interesting um
world that we're living in at the moment
i think what's beautiful for holly and
co
is we are we are right in the zeitgeist
of what people are feeling
so um you know when we're all looking at
you know the freelance economy when
we're all looking at the changes
remember not in the high street was
built when the high street was declining
holly and co is here when we're all
valuing mental health is something that
we do talk about
um changing the world purpose our
environment all these sorts of things
and so that is what i'm excited about
because we are
able to pivot able to move um and we're
building something that is at the time
that people need it
um we're going to have a lot of
displaced people
and they're going to need to be
entrepreneurial and they're going to
need to probably have their own
businesses and that's what i hope
we can do is provide them with the the
guide i suppose
and that's brings us to do what you love
love what you do
yeah yeah it's an amazing experience i'm
a dyslexic
so um writing
you know i remember not in high street
so if you had to check all my emails
that wasn't probably great because that
meant that i definitely thought i
couldn't and remember she could
rewrite the english dictionary so it was
probably the wrong person but
right person at the time um i didn't
write until
four years ago when i started my
instagram account holly tucker
and i now write a post every day but i
would have to get my founders to check
the post
because you know i couldn't do it
and you know again they raised me up
they said actually you can write so fast
forward
how on earth could i write a book so
during lockdown one
um i created something called sme sos
actually
for my community so i went live every
day on instagram
to try and demystify the news to try and
be there for them literally just be
there every 10 o'clock every morning
i'm just going to be here for you and we
can just do this together but what they
didn't know i was also writing a book in
the morning first thing
and it was one of the most beautiful
experiences ever
because people liked
who i was and how i wrote and um yeah
there were loads of spelling mistakes
and d's were bees and all this sort of
stuff
um but it was a wonderful experience and
it allowed me in a book to
almost put down everything we've spoken
about today
bringing color to gray being passionate
your energy you don't have to be great
at the p
l you have to be great at being you and
we'll figure
all the rest out at another stage
um that you are the founder that you're
the heartbeat
brand and purpose is one of the most
important things that you can
put into your business and so they're
micro chapters because all the small
businesses that i
uh virtually mentor don't have much time
so you can pick it up
kids can be screaming you can read a
micro chapter we created a
exclusive product range so every micro
chapter has a
almost merch that goes with it but
obviously all the 50 small businesses
that work with me
actually do what they love and love what
they do which i just love that circle
it's a color book which was funny
because business books normally aren't
color
but of course it had to be color and
it's um yeah sunday times bestseller and
i'm super proud of it
and i hope that now writing
books will be part of my life until
that age that we speak about where i'm
gonna wear lots of jewelry
big glasses and drink lots of wine
it's such a beautiful book business
books aren't usually like this they're
usually quite
exclusive in the way that they're
created and the way that they look and
then never color
so you look at it and think ah work yes
you know what i mean well that was the
whole purpose
for the creative bunch um that our small
businesses
you need to be able to love it and it
you know it needs to be
it needed to speak to you um and so many
it's been helping
so many people it's just insane and so
um
yeah it's just one of those moments in
my life that i can't believe
i get to be this lucky and i i imagine
because the same with my
my book did you did you realize it would
be
that rewarding because the effort to
create it is oh
it's a lot but then when you published
and you got it out there and you felt
the wave of
inbound yeah i didn't at all i didn't
even realize
you know it's like everything isn't it
when you're doing something
you're not actually you're so fast
forward you're like oh i've written that
book i really hope i get another b
you don't actually think about the
moment actually the book is born
you know so you're all you know up to
that point and then you slightly move on
you know you know and then the books
launch you're like
oh my god i've written a book look at
that person oh that was me
yes i remember that and because of
covert and timings and things like that
but the you know the process is not an
easy one right when the editor comes
back and goes
could you just insert that um thought
into that paragraph
thing you think really really does it
really necessary
um and yeah so it's just been wonderful
and
and as i said having people the amount
it was shared it was as if it was the
community's book and that
i never explicitly said that to the team
but that's exactly what we wanted it
needs to be the book
that represented the good life
businesses
that someone was talking their language
and so
that has been uh really humbling what a
wonderful
sort of demystifying both book but also
conversation today it's been an
absolute honor to meet you and to have
this conversation with you and you're
right you're one of those people that i
think culture really needs right now
someone that's been there and done it
come out the other side and said hear
all the things that are [ __ ] up about
the system and don't make the mistakes
that i made or fall into the traps that
i fell into
and i think that's um that's going to
liberate a lot of people but as you say
it's going to lead them to a much better
life so
i thank you for that because i think we
need more people in society that um
are willing to fight that fight and it
feels like such a selfless one even
though
it must be selfish to some degree
because it's giving you such a huge
sense of purpose
right yeah well i i can't believe this
gets to be my life get to meet you
yeah i'm a big fan of this podcast can't
believe i'm on it
um i was just saying that i was so
nervous i've only been on a few i'm very
good at talking to others
i'm so interested in other people's but
i i'm not very
you know i don't do this very often so
um it's been an
absolute honor to meet you and i wish
you um your good life business in the
future
well i'm going to let you know and
you're going to have to help me maybe
yeah some advice
thank you so much
[Music]
you